welcome back to Piers Morgan unsensitive
they're not swerving attacks or protest
pickets contemporary comedians face the
ever-present thread have been canceled
Jimmy Carr decided to run that Gauntlet
this weekend posting a selection of his
darkest jokes as tested on American
audiences they included this one about 9
11. when Zane left one direction for me
it was like 9 11.
yeah I didn't care about that either
well the clip has gone viral for all the
wrong reasons many people pointing out
the car simply isn't very funny but many
applauded his Free Speech sentiments
included my next guest Tim Dillon who
actually is very funny so let me bring
in uh Tim Tim great to have you on the
show first of all
um thank you for having me so there's
two strands to this one is is woke
killing comedy which I want to discuss
with you but secondly the Jimmy Carr
scenario where that joke has gone viral
and people have been hammering it for it
where do you sit with that
well I I think it's funny I think it's a
funny joke I think that people have
forgotten what jokes are and they're
things that are meant to get a reaction
from people to make people laugh
involuntarily
um they're not necessarily truth they
may have elements of Truth in them but
that's not what a joke is a joke is to
say sometimes the wrong thing uh to make
people laugh you know this is about we
all have a short amount of time on the
planet and we're supposed to be able to
kind of release some of the tension of
life through humor
um so I mean Jimmy Carr is a hilarious
comedian it's a funny joke he's not
running for Senate you know if he was
running for an elected office and he
said that and people were outraged I get
it you're a comedian saying that people
are outraged that's crazy
um and I don't think woke is killing
comedy I think woke is just making it's
drawing kind of a Line in the Sand and
the people that are refusing
to censor themselves and going out there
and just saying what they want to say or
having tremendous success well you're
one of them your friend Joe Rogan's
another he's a strictly comedian like
like you are in that sense he does this
brilliant podcast but he I think fights
back against his stuff Ricky Gervais
people like that I see do it but there's
a lot also who do get genuinely canceled
I mean comedians are getting canceled
they are getting you know buried by this
sort of woke mob what's your what's your
view of that and what can they do about
it
well I think it's a part of a larger
conversation about tech and about
technology and about free speech and
about misinformation I mean I think
comedy is one part of a much larger
conversation about how do you ensure
free speech on the internet and how do
you do that in a way that allows
companies to be profitable that allows
them to you know still have advertisers
like it's a very complicated issue you
know I mean like you know my aunt says a
lot of stuff she should be kicked off
Facebook you know I mean she's crazy but
she's my aunt she's not right a comedian
she doesn't have anybody following her
right it's like you know I think what
happens to a lot of comics unfortunately
is they end up
someone that an institution wants to
make an example out of and so that if
you censor one person or you kick one
person off or one person loses their job
then the other thousands of people are
now going to censor themselves and
they're not going to wade into that
territory but I feel like it's a
conversation about tech it's not it's
not only comedians this is happening too
it's like University professors and some
of those people are affected much more
because they don't have the ability to
go perform live like we do and kind of
say what we want in a comedy club or a
theater well I mean we're all seeing
comedians getting actually attacked you
know we saw the Chris Rock Will Smith uh
Fiasco the Oscars for example Dave
Chappelle was attacked on stage in Los
Angeles there's been other examples of
this that's a pretty sinister
step forward in this canceled culture
where people I mean for Will Smith to do
what he did was was an outrageous thing
in terms of the messages sent to people
that for a joke you would physically
assault somebody and the same with Dave
Chappelle
yeah it's crazy I mean the idea that you
would physically assault somebody for
any joke is uh completely absurd you
know I mean that's just you know I I
think when you when you think of words
as violence and you think that a
statement is a violent statement then it
makes sense that people are responding
to it with violence but thankfully that
seems to be a small minority of people
uh that have done that even though
they've done it very high profile ways
these are you know Will Smith was Major
it was you know seen around the world
but most people in comedy clubs are not
doing that although it has happened but
yeah we need to get back to words are
words and violence is violence yeah I
completely agree I want to talk about
two uh sets of people who are globally
known and I've had a lot said and
written about them the first on the
lighter end uh Harry and Megan the Duke
and Duchess of Sussex you have some
quite strong views of my favorites yeah
tell me tell me about your views of
these two I love them they're my they're
my favorites you know reality television
in America had kind of died down and
they've brought it back
um it's very interesting to make a
three-part documentary on Netflix about
how bad things are while living in a
castle I find that the lack of
self-awareness there to be very fun I
mean they're very funny they simulated
some type of car chase in New York City
that didn't really happen uh it was a
cab driver that was driving them around
said it did not happen
um they've you know I know people in Los
Angeles that they've texted and reached
out to because they kind of want to hang
out in these circles with celebrities
they got a big deal at Spotify spot if I
didn't make any money now the articles
are coming out that Spotify lost a lot
of money giving them money to do all
these things that they never ended up
really doing and nobody ended up
listening after the first few episodes
um so victimhood it makes me laugh and
when someone is clearly not a victim and
I think living in a castle being part of
a royal family
um would make you not a victim and to me
to portray yourself as somebody who's
having a rough go of it whilst living in
a castle with royal protection and then
leaving and flying to America to stay in
the home of a big celebrity and it's a
beautiful home they make me laugh I mean
I I like them I hope they don't go away
I hope they keep doing this I hope they
keep behaving shamefully it's great for
the tabloids it's great for us we keep
doing it keep simulating car chases
simulate terrorist attacks whatever they
want to do that keeps them in the news
I'm all for it
all you is amused by your country's
political situation right now because
many people outside of America are
looking at the prospect of Joe Biden who
can barely string a sentence together
all stand on his feet yeah coming up
against a guy in Donald Trump who's now
had nearly a hundred criminal charges
leveled against him the idea this is the
best America can do is ridiculous and
laughable but do you find it as funny
I find it funny it's it's it's clearly
disturbing because we're at the end of a
of an Empire and that's quite obvious to
everyone who's watching I mean children
who are paying attention to this can see
there's a problem
um but it is funny I mean you know the
other day Joe Biden walked off uh stage
she had finished giving a speech and
they just started playing like jazz
music and he wandered off the stage to
Jazz and it was like the most poetic
moment of like the sun setting on the
Empire like it's finally over this guy's
just kind of wandering off the stage to
like jazz piano as it ends yeah no it's
um it's disturbing but it's also you
know you gotta you gotta enjoy your life
and these are things you don't have a
lot of control over so you you really
have to just kind of laugh
it is funny you can't get away from it
um the Tim Dylan show hugely popular 568
000 subscribers uh congratulations on
that you have more sir you want more we
all want more I'm not gonna boast I've
got one and a half million I don't want
to tell you I've got one and a half
million subscribers I don't want to make
you feel jealous
yeah
uh on a series though it's great to have
you on the show please come back uh
you're a very funny guy and we
appreciate it
thank you thank you so much peers I'd
love to see you in London thank you
buddy well I'd love that take care